الكولونيل ، ما هي الإستراتيجية العسكرية الروسية في
الوقت الحالي
، هذا سؤال جيد حقًا ،
فما كان عليه في الأصل بالطبع هو
الإطاحة بالحكومة الأوكرانية ، لكن من
الواضح أنهم فشلوا في ذلك حينها ،
كانت الإستراتيجية التالية التي
نجحوا فيها أساسًا هي إنشاء أرض.  جسر
بين منطقة دونباس
والجزء الجنوبي من أوكرانيا بحيث كان ذلك
جزءًا مبكرًا من هدف الحرب أه الحرب
من جانب الروس ولكن
يبدو أن الاستراتيجية الآن تتمثل في الاحتفاظ
بما لديهم من احتلال و
منع أه الولايات المتحدة الناتو
وداعمي أوكرانيا الآخرين
فعليًا من تقديم أه المزيد من الأسلحة
إلى الأوكرانيين ومن حقًا أه
إطالة أمد الحرب بالشروط الأوكرانية
فما أراد الروس فعله هو
أنهم يريدون الاحتفاظ بأراضيهم ويريدون
التأكد من ذلك  ربما يمكنهم استعادة
جزء مما خسروه ولكن حتى الآن
هذا لا يعمل ، يبدو أن الجزء الآخر من
الاستراتيجية هو تجنيد أكبر
عدد
ممكن من الرجال في سن التجنيد.  m
في منطقة الحرب في أسرع وقت ممكن
واستخدامها كجزء من الحملة ولكن
هذا شيء يستغرق
وقتًا أطول بكثير مما
تتوقعه السلطات الروسية
وسيكون من الصعب جدًا
عليهم العمل  أنا أؤمن وأنت تعلم
ما نراه الآن